drew's been on a roll 32 years old 6-3
190 out of little rock and the
university of arkansas
he's won three straight
and three pitches and chisholm waves and
misses
that is high for ball four so the
marlins have their first base runner a
for atlanta the runner goes the pitch
popped up center of the diamond who
wants this freddie freeman says he's got
it and he does in foul ground good start
for drew smiley whose good work
continues pablo lopez had a nice nice
start his last time off picked up the
win against the nat six innings two runs
this guy likes to pitch inside you know
about the history between the marlins
and acuna and there we go first pitch of
the game he gets smoked
yeah as much as he pitched in last time
down in miami and didn't do it very well
kind of had a feeling that was going to
happen at some point tonight now brian
sticker is out to bark at the umpires
here
we'll see if any warnings are issued the
rest of the way but brian snitker has
grown very tired of this from miami
a lot of this was from jose arena
so don mattingly is out
i don't know if i agree with that
if you're not going to do it right away
then what are you what are you getting
together and have a meeting for
i mean if i'm mattingly i'm at rate if
i'm the rest of those coaches i'm a rape
that's mel stottlemyer jr
lopez i believe has been kicked out of
the game after one pitch
the marlins have hit a cunha five times
in his career and already
fireworks and it's not fourth of july
yet
i don't i don't agree with this
objection particularly if you didn't do
it right away then what are you getting
together for and deciding to do it
so stonemeyer leaves shaking his head
don mattingly is still pleating his case
lopez talking to one of the umpires and
now mattingly's been tossed
so manningly is done
lopez leading his case yeah that's not
pablo i mean pablo is trying to pitch
inside everybody tries to pitch acuna
inside and a game that ended in crazy
fashion last night
against the mets tonight's against miami
started about as oddly as we have ever
seen
as we proceed 1-0 pitch is popped into
center field that's going to drop for a
hit acuna got a late start he's going to
streak around second he's going to head
to third atlanta's got him at the
corners and no body out here in the
first inning
and he has been clutch this one in the
air to right that's playable for cooper
acuna is going to tag he is going to
come home it's an rbi for ozzy orbeez
and that run belongs to lopez it's one
nothing 58 runs batted in for all bees
[Applause]
and a tapper left side detweiler has it
off balance throw and they get him at
first
well he gets that one through the left
side to base it for augie law
as alfaro didn't get a curveball and
strikes out two away
smiley ready runner goes and pitch
strike three rung him up birdie thought
he earned ball four instead
smiley catches him looking
as he couldn't check his swing and
strikes out one man down two balls two
strikes
and a swing and a miss that's five
strikeouts for smiley he's punched out
four in a row
here it is
on the ground right to birdie he's got
it and ronald
jogs to first stand is retired for
out number two
2-0 pitch
back to the mound and detweiler a real
nice play
and he'll flip to first and that will
retire the side he has set down nine in
a row three great innings for ross
detwiler he was playing at first base
and had a good night three for six
knocked in a couple
the pitch is low ball four
and cooper's on with another walk let's
not get carried away tom the pitch is on
the ground toward third two long throws
there's one and not in time
that might go up oh it will just base it
into left field and duvall is on his way
to third throw from almante not in time
marlins have him on the corners now
that's what we're talking about marlins
fans that's what you want to see
[Applause]
double play ball
dance meet ozzy for one and a first a
double play thank you very much
miami's fourth inning threat is a race
anthony bender is into the ball game now
this will be his 23rd outing finally
after
all this time finally gave up a run
here he comes up empty and bender gets
the strikeout
and he gets him to chase
nike to get him all decked out for the
weekend as
bender how about that three strikeouts
out of the bullpen
but smiley is pitching great four shot
out innings he has scattered a couple of
singles
and alfaro didn't get the breaking ball
that's six strikeouts for drew smiley
and he hit it sharply ozzy had to flag
it down nice play and
that will retire the side wow that ball
was one of the hardest hit of the night
for miami
2-2 to heredia
and his swinging miss how about four
strikeouts out of the pen for anthony
bender
one out nobody on one and two to almonte
and strike three call
again
they'll try it again and it works again
how about six up and six down all
strikeout
way ahead of expectations
garrett cooper line drive base hit so
cooper has been on base three times
tonight
ryan snitker's going to go righty righty
here and bring on luke jackson to put
out a sixth inning fire drew smiley
pitched another gem tommy he leaves with
a one nothing lead on fourth of july
weekend
there goes coop here it comes and it
bounces away from contreras cooper
will stop at second
from jackson and a fly ball center
heredia going back
slowing now he's got room and jackson
gets him out of the sixth inning three
two is outside and the marlins have the
tying run aboard here to start the
seventh
and as green readies and delivers and a
swing and a miss alfaro's got the hat
trick aj mentor will come on and work
on the ground
dansby he's gonna fake to first throw
back to third and they got it what a
play heads up play by dansby swanson
rojas rounded the bag couldn't get back
he threw behind him tag applied inning
over
and the braves hold the lead
bender struck out all six little tapper
that might be trouble
it is
it's an infield hit that breaks the
spell
[Applause]
he's going good job pitch is a ball
alfaro's throw short hops the bag and
albie's in safely with a head first
slide and provide one he's ahead in the
count 2-0
[Applause]
on the ground hit to the left side
runner will go to third
but swanson
is out number two
on the ground hit toward third birdie's
got it
and his throw dug out by aguilar at
first and the braves can't cash in to
count
and he lost martay low one out walk
nothing in one and a first they got him
martay was thinking about going he got
picked off
and that is a couple of base running
blunders by the marlins in the last two
innings
and there's the start lead off walk
[Applause]
and sandoval takes ball four two blocks
in the inning from floro
and this one is lifted out to center
field long run in for marte it's going
to be jazz makes the over the shoulder
play
[Applause]
not an easy play by any stretch of the
imagination for jazz chisholm jr with
the shift on the left side of the
infield and a long run out there
will smith
will come on and try to close it out
3-2
and the marlins have their tying run
aboard
marlins got burned a couple of times
miggy though right center field this one
is going to drop for a base hit lacuna
junior's throw goes to third
and
sierra's out now trey hillman
immediately points to the dugout sierra
is staying at third base this is an
incredibly close play chief there who's
facing us is dan iasonia he's the second
base umpire today john lipka has us back
to us the third base umpire that made
the call we have our answer and the
marlins have runners on the corners
3-1 pitch
is low and in and the marlins will have
them loaded
trailers down on a knee the pitch
is popped up foul ground freddie
freeman's got it bertie's the second out
smith ready with his 01 pitch
high fly ball to left but it's right to
almonte
somehow subway will smith got out of it